[Music]
mr. Ramirez was told he was not under
arresting that he was refused use of the
bathroom that's violation of civil
rights you could wait and address this
at trial though I would like to address
it now I'm just saying mr. Israel if
guards in this courtroom would not allow
you to use the bathroom you would by all
definition be detained over the whole
tree of contempt if you continue to
pursue this you're asking me to obey an
erroneous court decision you tell me to
wait in my experience wait okay fine you
in contempt
[Music]
it's an enema of sunshine taking a
nanosecond off of your assembly line
rubber stamp existence is rail talk
about what to expect if you are arrested
we're gonna rap I don't mean hip hop I'm
sorry why are the sisters standing in a
brother city as gendered and sexist and
polite and patronizing and polite this
is run a deficit for years you're
inspiring I'm tired of doing the
impossible for the ungrateful
[Music]
you gotta make a living
take care of yourself I am no wish she
says hold up well stepworth a lot
don't tell nobody everything we discuss
will be not potential the man who did it
I know where he is
I want the reward cash the world is full
of wonderful things when can I move in I
just heard something about you from a
solid source you knew where I was god
that's you anytime I want
God these are dangerous people
Roman thank you sir thank you
[Music]
I'll begin with a break never sat in the
second look you don't just walk away
from this
[Music]
I could finish this
each one of us is greater than the worst
thing we've ever done
[Music]